[Music]
every single second inside every living
cell thousands of chemical reactions are
taking place these reactions are
performed by enzymes an enzyme is a
protein that catalyzes a chemical
reaction it initiates the reaction
speeds up the reactions progress and
make sure the outcome is always the same
these enzymes often work together to
form longer pathways such as the citric
acid cycle which is a series of chemical
reactions used by cells to generate
energy from carbohydrates the essential
tasks of life such as metabolism for
meeting synthesis and cell renewal and
growth are all regulated by enzymes the
life-sustaining power of enzymes lies in
the fact they catalyze reactions in mild
conditions of pH temperature and
atmospheric pressure the rates of
catalyzed reactions are millions to
trillions times faster than those of the
same reactions are catalyzed to speed up
a reaction in the absence of enzyme
additional energy would need to be
provided as heat which is jostles the
substrates and occasionally provides
enough energy to trigger a reaction in
the course of most reactions an unstable
and highly energetic transition state is
formed because the substrates are
transformed into products
an enzyme acts as a template for the
reaction my need to it substrate and
holding it in the proper position to
form the product an enzyme also
surrounds substrate with reactive groups
that stabilize a transition state making
it easier for the reaction to occur to
understand how enzymes work let's take a
closer look at a reaction in the citric
acid cycle that is catalyzed by the
enzyme accommodates a connotates binds
to its substrate citrate and removes a
hydroxyl group and a hydrogen atom to
form an intermediate Sakonnet 8 it then
adds the hydrogen the hydroxyl back in
slightly different positions to form the
product isocitrate
in the active site some amino acids are
perfectly positioned to recognize a
substrate and hold it in the optimal
position for the reaction to begin some
amino acids are involved in recognizing
and holding the substrate other amino
acids are directly involved in catalysis
histidine 101 acts as an acid by
donating its proton thanks to the
chemical environment of serine 642 it
can act as a base by accepting the
proton from the substrate the active
side of McConaughey's also contains an
iron sulfur cluster that stabilizes the
substrate electrostatically
and helps to position at relative to the
catalytic residues the first step in the
reaction is dehydration in this step
christening acts as an acid and
protonates the hydroxyl on the substrate
allowing it to leave as a water molecule
Sirian then acts as a base extracting a
hydrogen atom from the opposite side of
the substrate forming the intermediate
Sakonnet 8 Sakonnet 8 then flips upside
down and the complementary hydration
reaction is performed in this step
histidine grabs a hydrogen atom from a
passing water molecule placing the
resulting hydroxyl group back onto the
substrate Sirian then returns its
hydrogen atom and the final product Isis
citrate is released notice that the
enzyme itself was not changed by the
reaction it extracted the hydroxyl group
and a hydrogen atom and then put them
back the starting and ending in the same
state this is the hallmark of a catalyst
when it finishes a reaction it is ready
for the next so it can perform thousands
of reactions in row notice also the
shape of an active site is often
flexible many enzymes surround their
substrates and closing them to form the
perfect environment for a reaction
enzymes are fundamental to life lovers
working every second of every day to
maintain life processes in every cell in
every living creature on the planet
[Music]
[Music]